this video is sponsored by Squarespace
make your next move
hey wisecrack jared here again this time
to discuss the punching bag of the DC
Universe no not that one this one cherry
[Music]
now since everybody's already beat the
film up for its shameless franchise
plugging it's slow plotting and well
that we're going to focus on something
else
Batman V Superman's ideological failings
so let's see if it bleeds welcome is
wisecrack Edition on Batman V Superman
what went wrong and of course spoilers
ahead one of the biggest challenges
facing the architects of the DC EU is
how to make Superman a relatable
character after all it's hard to
identify with an indestructible selfless
god-like figure so what was their
solution well a pretty smart one if you
asked me that kind of did what was done
in the last temptation of Christ took a
benevolent Messiah figure and emphasized
his vulnerabilities flaws and most
importantly doubts I'm a man like
everybody else doubts as to whether he
can or should carry the burden of divine
status essentially making him more human
we see this push and pull as Superman
decides between being a benevolent
Savior or just focusing on what matters
to him namely Lois the problem is this
Boches a fundamental part of having a
movie about the rivalry between Batman
and Superman namely having them embody
different ideologies this doesn't really
happen
enter Batman V Superman's biggest
inspiration Frank Miller's graphic novel
The Dark Knight Returns the film takes a
lot of its cues from this work an older
Bruce Wayne Czech Superman being hit by
a nuke and then healed by the Sun oh
yeah Robins memorialized costume in
Batman's lair yup even the central fight
between Batman and Superman is more or
less taken from the graphic novel with
Superman trying to reason with Batman
and Batman having none of it but beneath
the mask of both the Dark Knight Returns
and Batman V Superman flies an unlikely
inspiration one that solidifies the
all-important ideal
logical distinction between Batman and
Superman I'm Rand's The Fountainhead
well at least it does in the graphic
novel
Rand's novel follows Howard Roark an
experimental architect who faces near
constant opposition from the rigid
establishment and yeah I know you're
thinking what the hell do superheroes
punching each other have to do with
architecture well not only has Zack
Snyder been trying to make The
Fountainhead movie for years but Frank
Miller's cites Rand as a big influence
on his work per Miller he was drawn
again and again to Rand's ideas and how
she took the fate of humanity out of the
hands of the convenient Big Brother and
into the hands of individuals in
particular buff Miller and Snyder seem
drawn to rands depiction of male heroes
in the fountainhead protagonists Howard
Roark is the ideal man a man who no
matter the obstacles achieves his goals
and never gives up an inch on his
integrity even if that leads to conflict
with others this Randian hero is defined
by ethical egoism the belief that the
best course of action is always what's
in your best interest only they're
pursuing your own self-interest can you
ever hope to achieve happiness a central
tenant of iron Rand's philosophy
objectivism Tyrande
a male hero must be a radical
individualist unwilling to bend smarter
than everyone else and well not too
shabby on the eyes sound familiar to a
certain Dark Knight rands ideal man fits
Miller's Batman to a tee he's a super
rich handsome playboy with a genius
intellect who refuses to bend to
anyone's will but his own it's Batman's
adherence to Randian egoism fet enables
and ideological conflict between Batman
and Superman individualism /
collectivism we are criminals Clark we
always have been
you're still 1 - only difference is you
have a boss
and you answer to no one Batman faces
constant obstruction from the US
government who tasks the ultimate
conformist to stop him Superman in
Miller's work Superman is the anti Rand
figure a character whose
self-sacrificing moral righteousness and
commitment to doing good marks him as a
government stooge either shut it down or
one of these days someone with authority
is gonna tell me to come stop you much
of the drama in Miller's graphic novel
stems from these differing ideologies
the individualism of Batman versus the
conformism of Superman now whether you
agree or not with Rand's philosophy
there's no denying that miller
successfully instilled the spirit of her
theories to create a compelling interior
conflict between our two Titans so while
Frank Miller pulled this off with flying
colors Batman V Superman's integration
of this philosophy is where it all goes
wrong first let's give props to what
they get right Batman a flex version is
pretty much in line with Miller's Randy
and take on the character he's handsome
almost supernaturally athletic smarter
than everyone else and catnip for the
ladies Batman's also a complete
individualist refusing to bend his will
to anyone even the judicial process or
criminals after they've always been
criminals
well thanks jack even brands criminals
so they'll be shanked in prison now I
watched the whole movie being pretty
confused as to why Batman wanted to
fight Superman in the first place but
here - I think there's a nod to Rand if
Batman is so concerned about this
god-like Superman it's because any kind
of god ruins the whole ethical egoism
thing how are you supposed to make your
own choices based on your own
rationality when there's something
objectively greater than you Rand was
famously an atheist for this reason so
they get this Randian version of Batman
right but it's with the depiction of
Superman that things begin to get
muddled they couldn't create a purely
benevolent do-gooder Superman because
that would be boring and impossible to
relate to conversely they decide not to
make him the collectivist stooge that
Miller made him because well the
audience is supposed to like him just as
much as Batman and we've got Justice
League films to make people so what did
they do
previous depictions of Superman have
focused on his self-sacrificing goodness
Christopher Reeves iconic portrayal
Superman doesn't save people for his own
betterment but simply because it's the
right thing to do I'm here to fight for
truth and justice in the American Way
be it rescuing a cat from a tree or
catching Lois from plummeting to her
death the Superman of Batman V Superman
however looks like he's stuck performing
the most tiresome nine-to-five job
imaginable
since gods shouldn't whine about saving
humanity the film constantly undercuts
the perception of Superman as a purely
benevolent christ-like hero which later
Batman just straight-up tell Superman
face-to-face
Superman's crisis manifests into two
warring identities the classic Superman
the god benevolent and Christopher
Reeves like and Superman the man which
for Snyder means a Randian Objectivist
ie a guy who flies to the Middle East to
save Lois but leaves all the other
innocents to die this internal conflict
is pretty bluntly stated by Martha Kent
be their hero be their monument be their
angel be anything they need you be or be
none of it
[Music]
you don't know this for Martha there's
no difference between choosing to be a
benevolent Messiah or a self-involved
Objectivist both are equally valid the
important thing is that it's Clark's
choice to make and this rational choice
is what marks a Randian hero later the
ghost of Jonathan Kent gives Clark his
own advice revealing a time he
selflessly saved his farm from a flood
yet unbeknownst to him the water went
upstream flooding another nearby farm
well ain't my hero cake their horses
were drowning I used to hear him wailing
in my sleep Jonathan Kent here
dismantles the notion of selfless
heroism
there's simply no point to being the
classic selfless do-gooder Superman
because there will always be another
flooded farm you couldn't stop when
Clark asks ghost at how he could live
with himself after dooming the nearby
farm he responds when I Met Your Mother
she gave me faith that there's good in
this world she was my world dream
Jonathan is kind of like a ghost of
Objectivism past suggesting that true
moral righteousness comes from bettering
yourself pursuing your own self-interest
and protecting the ones you love because
they in turn bring you happiness ethical
egoism in a nutshell so what choice does
Superman ultimately make Messiah or
Randian hero actually he doesn't really
make a choice at all at first Superman
seems to embrace Jonathan's objectivism
returning to Metropolis only to save the
people who really matter to him aka
Louis and Martha he even echoes
Jonathan's parting words telling Lois no
you so what's his decision both as a
benevolent Savior he takes
responsibility for the well-being of the
whole planet but as an Objectivist he
also mentions he's doing it all for Lois
five seconds later Superman sacrifices
himself in the most messianic fashion
possible price like with his arms spread
out heck there's even a makeshift cross
behind Superman's corpse
Superman's ambiguous philosophy becomes
problematic since Batman V Superman is
framed as an ideological conflict
between Batman and Superman yet none
actually exists the first time Bruce and
Clark meet the bill pays lip service to
what should be their differing beliefs
Bruce doesn't like how metropolis and
the world blindly trust Superman by
labeling him as a savior
Bruce questions the very possibility of
a superhuman benevolent Savior because
as he's seen even the best can turn bad
you just have a bad history with freaks
dressed like clowns and Clark thinks
Batman is a vigilante who needs to be
put in check
civil liberties have been trampled on in
your city good people living in fear
this is a similar ideological conflict
as Miller's The Dark Knight Returns but
Batman V Superman instead of exploring
the dynamic further immediately up ends
it the world turns against Superman
headline end of love affair with men in
the sky question mark because like
Batman he acts on his own accord I'm not
saying he shouldn't act I'm saying he
should not even elaborate and by using
objectivism to make Superman more
relatable the film ends up shooting
itself in the foot because now there's
almost no ideological difference between
Batman and Superman so in a film that
requires a conflict based on differing
ideals that's based on a source material
showcasing this ideological divide
Batman V Superman instead becomes a
Randy and hero versus a maybe sort of
Randy and hero who can't decide if he
wants to be the divine Savior the world
wants him to be so in the end the film
presents no preference of heroics
whether one should sacrifice oneself for
the greater good or only keep their own
interests in mind is immaterial because
the solution presented isn't that one
kind of heroics needs to be put in check
while another promoted rather the
message is
or heroes Aquaman the flash cyborg and
that they all should form their own team
help me find the others like you aka the
Justice League so instead of the film
espousing a clear philosophy everything
just becomes muddled quite simply it's a
mess but it's an ambitious mess and for
that it deserves credit and hey maybe
Justice League will get it right thanks
for watching wisecrack peace hey guys
thanks again for watching if there's one
thing we've learned from the follies a
Batman V Superman there's nothing wrong
with having grand ambitions but just
make sure you have the tools to do it
right whether you're making Batman
fanfiction independent art or starting a
business you can confidently make your
next move with Squarespace so start your
free trial today at squarespace.com
slash wisecrack and get 10% off your
first purchase when you use the offer
code wisecrack with Squarespace you can
build a super cool and stylish website
fast
they've got professionally designed
templates that look great and intuitive
tools that are so easy you really don't
need to know a thing about coding to
create something that looks awesome we
actually use Squarespace to create a
site for our new show fill legends that
launched over at the film theorist
Channel it took us less than an hour to
use they're super easy platform to
create a great looking site and I've
never coded a single thing in my life so
trust me if I can do it you can do it I
head over to Squarespace calm slash
wisecrack to start your free trial today
don't forget to enter the offer code
wisecrack to get 10% off your first
purchase and thanks a lot to Squarespace
for sponsoring this video
that's all for now wisecrack don't
forget to subscribe and bring that bail
thanks again for the support peace